oh oh i think we got him hello i can
hear you now
welcome aboard all right guys we got him
we had the speaker down
we got him we got him folks speaker goes
down we are here
right now hold on let me call you right
now i can hear you i can hear you
all right well we got him we're closer
we're closer than we were
we're getting there so we'll we'll give
it a shot here they're gonna give me a
call back
here we go here we go all right we're
here i believe we are live right now
with ring of honor star maria manic and
of course
uh the man who needs no introduction
teddy hart uh
live on the night wave program how you
guys doing tonight
can you see us and hear us i can see and
hear you yeah i can't you probably can't
see me because i have to use my camera
for obs so they can see the show but uh
i can hear you guys fine
with you the whole time no i well it's
because
otherwise i gotta kill the [ __ ] video
feed that's going out
and this is kind of i i i work all your
technology and [ __ ]
because you're supposed to be a computer
guy and imagine i'm supposed i'm a
a barely literate uh high spot
monkey attempted uh according to your
story uh murder or a bunch of other
critiques [ __ ] so you should be able to
figure out how to be able to [ __ ]
show yourself while we show ourselves
because i like to see your face when you
talk to me
i respect right well i mean i die even
if it's online
i can't see your face when you're
talking all that [ __ ] when you're
talking to me face to face for real i
want to see your face because i want to
be your friend
but it's hard to be friends with a
[ __ ] black screen you know what i
mean i i understand but i don't have two
video cards uh
so we'd have to really just do this but
if we have a good interview and we're
cool next time we do this can you maybe
figure out how to do that i'll be even
willing to split the cost with the honor
just so you could have a better show for
your fans because my job the only reason
i do this is because
i think you must be pretty intelligent
but you're challenging me to talk to you
man to man because i think you actually
want to have a
well hang on hang on hang on you kind of
challenged me let's be fair here i could
uh
you know i can't be a [ __ ] murderer
bro did i call you a murderer though
dude are you unless you're kidding
around unless you're kidding around you
called me a [ __ ] murderer you said
some girl's missing because they're
[ __ ] me dude i'm a nice guy i tried
to help her out
i can't help that literally my ex-wife
was a [ __ ] undercover cop
and worked for the police for 17 years
and she was in the department of escort
agencies and prostitution because it's
completely legal in canada
and especially in alberta it's the way
they catch a lot of dumb ass child
because they all go through the system
because prostitution's legal
samantha fiddler great person wasn't a
prostitute she might have been a
stripper in canada as far as i knew i
knew it for three months before she came
to florida
all right all right all right all right
all right let me let me get all right
so you will let you you didn't live with
her you didn't so you didn't live with
her in 2014.
i never called you a murderer i'm smart
enough broadcaster to not [ __ ]
put myself in that position so let's
let's just have a chat right now
we're not playing [ __ ] word games
here you know what you implied if i
imply the black is black and the color's
black and i don't see the color black
but i tell you it's the darkest color in
the [ __ ] rainbow
and you'll figure out black's the only
color that's not in the rainbow my
friend so i'm not gonna talk [ __ ]
black and white [ __ ] you're very
smart
you're coming out of the gate real hard
[Music]
when we become friends first of all
nobody called you a murderer nobody
called you a murderer
but you do have what you said all right
well we'll get right
into it so did you all right look we
could do it either way but
nobody ever called you a murderer but
you do have a lot of conflicting
you've told a lot of weird conflicting
stories
and you've told a lot of weird things
like like
you only knew this girl for a couple
months but like let's be fair i'm here
did you
you didn't live with her in 2014 up in
edmonton with her kids you didn't run
off with her jaguar and her passport
this is stuff i'm seeing in text
messages man and i'm not the one who
[ __ ] started the room
no let me [ __ ] talk this is my
[ __ ] show let me [ __ ] talk for a
second
you don't just come in and start talking
over me and [ __ ] cut a promo on me
you let me [ __ ] talk too
now listen i'm not the one who [ __ ]
started these rumors all right
all of my ex-living girlfriends are
[ __ ] alive and accounted for
so if you want to [ __ ] get mad get
mad at bodyslam.net
get mad at the [ __ ] dirt sheets i'm
not the one who [ __ ] started the
rumors i do a [ __ ] comedy show
and i [ __ ] cover [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
relevant so
you didn't live with samantha and her
kids in 2014 in edmonton
you never you never said that they were
like a family now are you going to keep
answering
asking the same question i heard the
question three times i'll answer all
three of them
did i live with samantha fiddler for
less than a month you can ask machu go
because i was dating her at the time and
i was in texas i went back to deal with
the trial
so yeah i beat the trial in canada saw
samantha fiddler at a strip club
introduced her to my friend she wanted
to become what you call
uh some kind of wrestler or mma star she
knew that our family
and the girl that knew this girl her
boyfriend
also does mma samantha fiddler's dad
used to be a wrestler
trained with lance storm and a bunch of
guys and ed langley was his trainer so i
actually met her dad and he said she's a
great fighter i've been training her for
boxing for years
she's a tough girl she's got three kids
so i met her daughters introduced them
to my
to my family because she's a nice woman
with three kids that's why i take
offense when people are saying this and
i'm so glad you're a comedian guy i
didn't know that
i apologize for taking that tone i
thought you were the guy that was
making up this [ __ ] i don't know where
the source of information is because i
don't go on the computer a lot
so i thought this was your story that
you brought back up three years later
how could this be my [ __ ] story i
started covering this
weeks months after this [ __ ] got out so
i should have done my homework a little
bit on who you are so i apologize
but what i'm trying to get through to
you is that it's a simple thing for you
because you're smart you sound like
you're pretty intelligent to go okay
after this guy explained it to me
there's no [ __ ] way it could be him
that's sad
that that kind of [ __ ] would be smeared
about you because it's so far-fetched
that i would be like
listen man i don't know what happened to
her because it's three simple things
i brought her down to wrestle she didn't
yeah well chasing her
chase in school yeah i did does it have
anything to do with chasing and what he
had happened to him in his [ __ ] life
what he had happened to him what he had
happened to him
sir do you specify specified
what happened he had sex with a child he
had sex with a child is what he did
he didn't have anything happened to him
i'm asking about that i'm not asking
about that i'm asking you
you asked i i asked you something and
then you replied back to something and i
said
what happened to jason that's that's
what happened to him because what
happened to him was she was sent down
there
to train because he runs a good school
i'm not the [ __ ] police and i'm not
judging anything that happened with him
and a 17 year old [ __ ] girl or 19
year old girl 13 year old girl
i don't know what the [ __ ] story was and
i don't think if you know the story that
well then deal with him i've read the
police reports yes i know the story
so unbelievable so if someone [ __ ] up
in life and makes a mistake
that's a little more than a [ __ ]
mistake i got a dui a couple of years
ago that's a mistake
for the rest of your life no no no but
i'm not a kid you see the difference
well again one is a [ __ ] compulsion
one is a [ __ ] and i understand his
hype talk on the internet to call a guy
a kid
and get a lot of heat for it but again
there's a lot of pieces of [ __ ] that
have been in wrestling my friend and i'm
not judging anything yeah and a lot of
them are involved in team vision dumb
jobs [ __ ] wrestling
where you brought someone to school or a
girl to a school
and the schools are all over the [ __ ]
planet and someone runs a good school
happens to be jason i'm going to bring
her to the school that runs a good
school because i've seen him produce
people that know how to wrestle
and that's all i can go on and i'm not
saying anything about what i did or he
did or you did or any of our past i'm
just going on if i'm a guy who's trying
to bring a girl who's got a three
[ __ ]
three kids on her plate to feed and she
wants to know how she's gonna make money
immediately in mma and maybe wrestling
then i'll bring her to a school like
florida because there's a place called
mma and there's a place called wrestling
happens to be in this state
you can go to the same city and deal
both at a pretty competitive level so
there's there's like there's like 17
wrestling schools in orlando alone
it's the team vision dojo seems to only
have the one have the only one that has
like [ __ ]
domestic abusers and kitty diddlers and
child
[ __ ] the guy that just [ __ ]
murders pregnant stepmom
there seems to be a real [ __ ] issue
with the teamvision dojo
and there's a million other [ __ ]
schools out there there's a thousand
schools in florida
should then or is your argument with me
for picking a bad school for samantha
sir or is it no i'm trying to figure out
some of the inconsistencies in your
stories
i caused her to go missing you know you
but listen you said that there was no
way you could have made her go missing
right because you were in jail
you were in jail there's no way rock
solid alibi the problem there is that
you were arrested on december 12th in
arlington texas
and she went missing in november 16th
2016.
so there's there's where's the [ __ ]
where's that month like
you you kind of glance you you kind of
glaze over a lot of big facts here
i've i've seen the text messages you
guys were together on and off from 2014
to [ __ ] 2016.
text messages you have to let me know
what you're seeing sir you're telling me
something i'm talking to you sir because
you sound like a rat cop that doesn't
have the right information the text
messages between
you sir until you figure out what the
[ __ ] you're talking about the text
messages between samantha
and stacey when did i get arrested first
in arlington sir
what what when when was it december 12
2016. arlington texas for
uh i believe battery on an elderly or a
kid or some [ __ ]
uh nope a guy tried to burn a house down
and he had drugs on him security
arrested him
he got away from the security guards two
days later he came back said he was
disabled
took it to court and ended up getting
off the charges with probation for the
dui
and the rest of it got dropped just like
the case in canada got dropped because
there was no proof of anything because
it didn't happen
and that was just december 12th right
just like if you really know the story
again with the situation with samantha
it was impossible
because she was in jail i don't know
when she got released because i never
spoke to her again after i went to jail
the first time she got released
the day before november 16th did you do
your homework you just checked one date
and then said you knew something there's
a lot of things i [ __ ] mulled over
i would like to know what they are
please write them down if you want so
she got out of jail on november 15th she
went missing the very next day november
16
2016. there's a huge gap in time but
a huge gap in time that you're not
explaining where were you that time
who's andre corbell do you know andre
corbett how did she go missing
and when how do you know she went
missing that day it's called the
it's called the internet there's a whole
[ __ ] case file on this girl it's not
like i didn't pull this [ __ ] out of my
ass
why does the brevard county police
department not have me on the list as a
suspect
and [ __ ] everyone in this place is
basically judges lawyers and cops
what does brevard county have to do with
this this was polk county
pardon me this was polk county not
brevard county and the reason is not
county it was in because i'm not the one
looking at the [ __ ] because i don't got
to worry about it you're trying to
figure out what county it was i'm
telling you the brevard county sheriff's
department checked it out just to make
sure because of what you said
we wanted to double check our facts
before we went on here and opened our
mouths like you running your [ __ ]
mouth
acting like you're a big shot detective
when you're not well look first of all
do you know andre corbell
dude yeah i know andre corbell so andre
corbell went on a
really odd he he made a whole bunch of
uncorroborated statements that
uh this girl was a junkie she was a
prostitute a lot of victim-blaming [ __ ]
a lot of white knighting for you
and it might have been true so you're
you you're asserting that you're
asserting that
uh samantha was a prostitute and a drug
user
have to say samantha before i met her
was doing some pretty stupid drugs yeah
for sure in 2014. i don't tolerate
cocaine
in my [ __ ] group never tried it in my
life never took a painkiller in my life
never tried crystal meth in my life
never done a [ __ ] pill besides what
is it called the [ __ ] tylenol pm
no i didn't take that [ __ ]
either been to rehab four times for
marijuana sir and it's a promo
because it's true don't i don't play
games with [ __ ] stupid
homes bro you're dealing with a [ __ ]
very smart guy like me who works in law
enforcement for 20 [ __ ] years i'm
helping police officers be way smarter
what are you [ __ ] elvis presley now
what is this [ __ ] you're not
you're not a cop you know you're no more
cop than i am
rewind it and listen to it again if you
missed it so
no okay so andrew so you're you're going
to back up andre corbell's assertions
that this girl was just a junkie
prostitute your own [ __ ] assumptions
that andre corbie
has any reason to lie about this girl
why would he lie about it she was
[ __ ] medicine i don't know
i don't have a bunch of [ __ ] smoking
crack before i met her
okay she's a good mother but i can't
[ __ ] i can't uh sit there and agree
on her choices when i met her we got her
in sheep we took her to the gym we fed
her protein we fed her [ __ ]
a lot of water and took her to the
[ __ ] gym and to the gym into the
martial arts facility in canada and got
her memberships which we have proof of
to i think that a little place called
the leisure center so where kids can go
swim
and do ballet and play the piano my
cousin who's a little bit of a movie
star now in canada
babysat her kids for weeks because her
kids were very nice little girls three
of them
i would never [ __ ] do anything to
harm that woman only help her out but
you can't help people that are [ __ ]
destined to be
to be in that situation she had a nice
job she quit the job
she i have no idea what she did she took
one punch in the face in the wrestling
thing or in the boxing thing training on
her own from what i heard
and she didn't like it she said she can
make her own money landscaping jagmark
how could a mother of three with no
money afford a [ __ ] brandon jaguar
how stupid does that sound to you i
don't know again
between her and stacy angel i'm just
telling you what i'm seeing
how could samantha afford a jaguar where
did she get the [ __ ] money from
i don't know where do you get your money
from where do i get my money from
magically medical marijuana grow-ops all
over [ __ ] any place that's legalized
for medical weed in the last 13 years
that's where i got my money from signed
with wwe when i was 18 years old
that's where i got my money from uh
independent wrestling no not really
matt ratz i ran that raised seven
million [ __ ] dollars for that show
i don't know where to get my money from
my dad's a wealthy businessman three
generations of wealth
we're wealth russian who have a bunch of
other nationalities italian greek
i'm not a wrestler that makes money on
wrestling just like i don't know one
[ __ ] thing about you until you cut a
promo on me and tell me where are you
from
well it sounds like you guys had a lot
of
it sounds like you guys had see i wanted
to get to know each other but you came
right out the gate so let's just get
right into it
so you you from what you've described to
me you have described a lot of ups and
downs for a relationship that only
lasted three months
why do you only refer to samantha in
definitive past tense
if someone goes missing in my mind for
more than a year
with an expired passport i don't think
she's alive anymore and i
pray to god she is but i would think
something happened to her because she's
a pretty good mother and i think she
would have got back to her kids somehow
at least or talked to her mother or her
dad or somebody because
her dad loved her a lot he was a great
guy and i'm saying this in past tense
because i don't know if i'll meet him
again in the future
to me every day is my first day and my
last day i live that life basically
based on i don't know what's going to
happen tomorrow i try to plan for a safe
day
but i can't predict what samantha
fiddler is going to do when she gets out
of jail
i didn't get her put in jail wasn't
anywhere nearer so if you really want to
get more into it again call the cops do
crime stoppers
set it up and they'll do the same thing
that anyone other detectives already
done
and they say that guy can't be the guy
that did it and he's sure he feels
shitty about the situation
but you're taking work out of my [ __ ]
mouth and my hands because i talk to
make money in wrestling
and i motivate kids by running a pretty
good wrestling school for 20 years
and i helped a lot of guys get into
wrestling business or get a good match
okay i don't know if you're a big
wrestling fan or not but i try to be a
guy that risked his life so guys like
you clap and go that guy's cool man it's
totally fake this is shit's
complete work and he's actually jumping
off the top ropes like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
just so because some guy in the audience
is clapping for him but nobody's denying
you're a talented guy teddy i've said it
on my own show
but they're again because i want to make
you smile my friend because i want to
make you believe in me but not think i
would ever hurt a kid or a girl that's
never something i would do
but i know but that's exactly the kind
of things people say and again i've
never accused you of anything
i have gone off of you want to like i
said you want to take it up take it up
with bodyslam.net
and take it up with the people that made
all these [ __ ] twitter threads and
take it up with the people who've been
contacting me
these people want to know why you say
you only knew this girl for three months
but you [ __ ] knew her back in twenty
you knew her back in 2014
and in 2016 you're doing [ __ ] rolling
stone articles with her and
she's you're proud of you know how long
i knew her for i knew her for three
months then she came down to florida
she came down to florida with us i
didn't see her for another month or two
after that then it came back again
and she was still down here check the
storyline i'm sorry if i said i've known
her for three months
i only was with her for three months
that's how much time you said i spent
with her that was on two different
vacations that i went back for so i went
back and forth not to see just her to
deal with my court case
so yeah i just got off two charges in
canada and i'm about to [ __ ] kidnap
and take some at the fiddler and take
her jaguar when she has zero credit
no money she can't afford to get fake
tits so but she asks us because she
thinks she's gonna fight and we can make
money as fight promoters because we have
been [ __ ] promoting fights for 25
years
30 40 50 60 years my family's been doing
promoting and fighting and making money
off guys and girls and midgets
and giants and all sorts of other [ __ ] i
bring a [ __ ] cat to the ring for
[ __ ] sake but i make money off
promoting things samantha fiddler great
story mother of three
boxing champion her dad's an ex-wrestler
see if we can give her a push
my friend likes her he wants to date her
they're the ones that wanted to hook up
not me and her so that's another thing
that people have just
she was never my girlfriend and i wasn't
[ __ ] her
people wait now she was never your
girlfriend she was never my girlfriend i
wasn't [ __ ] her
that's that's the other thing people
[ __ ] think she was she liked my
friend
she was with my friend the only reason
she hung out with me was because my
friend
and his kids and her kids were always
dealing with the situation of
if they stay with him where do they want
to live and she didn't want to live in
canada anymore
so he said he'd take care of her whole
family and everything would be cool with
her and she said that's fine i'll talk
to my parents and her parents said they
take care of her kids instead
so she got permission to leave the
country basically from her parents who
are watching her three kids
and safe hands to be a wrestler and to
be possibly an mma fighter and she
said mma was her thing not wrestling she
didn't like wrestling that much but it
was a backup plan
so that was all we're trying to do is
just get her a few fights and dude
she did her own thing down here and
that's that's all i can really say to
you about it because
my interactions with her would be
sparingly she lived in a [ __ ] mansion
down here
with some guy from jason's wrestling
school and another guy's wrestling
school
and saint laurent i think and those guys
ran a school so i think that was the
only one of their students that they had
a house
she stayed at that guy's house i was
like was a complete [ __ ] from what i
heard
to that guy and his family all right
look he kicked it out so so why is it
that rolling stone in 2016 says
beside him speaking of you sam fiddler
his wrestling student come girlfriend
rests sleepily in a triple xl purple fur
road one of the many outlandish
wrestling costumes her mentor come
boyfriend has
at hand now if i'm not dating somebody
i'm going to tell the [ __ ] magazine
hey
oh i'm not really dating this girl
please continue i waited for you to talk
so rolling stones i wish it was all true
but it wasn't so they decided it sounded
better than
a girl that just met teddy hart that
wanted fake tits because she was a good
stripper and
sucked my friend's dick for real but
that's the story and my friend liked her
so he wanted to buy her fake tits so he
did
and uh he got me a jaguar to drive down
to florida because he thought i was
gonna leave samantha fiddler
uh with him and he was upset after that
he got the jag for me
and too bad for me i have good friends
and i'm not the only one that doesn't
[ __ ] make the payment samantha has
zero dollars so
i make the payments on my car and i
drive down there she wants to get a ride
down there to do mma
so and wrestle possibly yeah
kids are taken care of can i come with
you sure my kids are taken care of
so some hot chick that my friend's
[ __ ] hanging out with and he wants
her to do well
and he's a sponsor and he says yeah i
got her i got her taken care of i'll
help her kids out if she needs anything
anyway so we don't we don't have to
worry about it
and she [ __ ] has an opportunity of a
lifetime
and decides to [ __ ] blow it and now
i'm hearing about it yeah of course it's
disappointing but
maybe i knew her for a total of what i
guess five months total but three months
i was hanging out with her
and nobody saw me kissing her or [ __ ]
her or doing anything with her
i slept over at her house i slept in her
bed remember there's another story my
dick doesn't really work either because
i've been uh
taking anabolic steroids on and off
since i had a prescription when i was 32
years old
so i've never been a guy that really
keeps a wife because usually they just
end up getting to be
back to what they wanted to be which is
lesbians most of the girls i hate are
lesbians
i watched enough maria and ted videos to
know that your dick works ted come on
it works for maria now he's lying what a
coincidence
it's a christmas miracle he's lying i
didn't say i had a lipstick for you
i'm saying though my dick didn't work i
also [ __ ] i'm a lot smarter now with
stretching
and a lot smarter after going to jail
for [ __ ] a year he said i've watched
it
so what i'm saying is why doesn't why
doesn't why doesn't rolling stone
because i know you're like
because like because rolling stone
couldn't say student and girl who was
stuck on my friend's dick and bought a
jaguar or whatever
what about your student what about like
just his student
right yeah yeah it's daddy and he's got
his student here
wrapped up in his robes laying around
his house
i just beat a charge in canada a huge
charge
lost my million dollar house waiting and
i actually beat the charges again
was it considered it was a joke but if
you get charged for something you have
to go to court and fight it
so i beat the charges but during that
time she had a house
we paid the rent we paid for the car not
hers not ours but hers
and ours and paid for all the groceries
and helped her out
and that was that was the simple
weirdest people that are trying to help
her out
but we didn't we're not pieces of [ __ ]
my family's been helping people out for
[ __ ] years
the casualized family's been helping
people out for years they're a big fine
you know he's the one that took care of
all my cats 37 cats of mine for four
years he ran the cat sanctuary for me
and that's where samantha fiddler went
and that's who she's friends with
like he'll say the same thing like she
was a great potenti her potential was
unbelievable she was a very smart girl
and it was a [ __ ] brutal thing that
happened but
she had probably what was brutal what
was brutal
the situation of having three kids and
being all stuck by herself basically and
and nobody really going to be able to
help her out the guy that was her
boyfriend was actually a stand-up guy
and took one of her kids
and i met him after but from what he
said she had a problem with the other
guy from before
doing drugs with him and he went to jail
for it he was a
he i'm not going to say anything bad
about the guy but i wouldn't i would
think you'd call him
a piece of [ __ ] i'm not gonna say
anything more than that but i don't
think
from what i hear of your moral standing
and how you think of something and i
applaud
i have credit and a respect for how you
think something i want to know the truth
and if you want to hear me talk about
that instead of wrestling and [ __ ]
other bunch of crazy [ __ ] wrestling
stories and this is what we want to talk
about
cool eventually we'll be talking about
something else and you probably will end
up being my friend i would think because
we've had it
you know a three-hour lecture or talk or
a decision-making uh process where
you're gonna go yeah yep no
yeah and we'll talk about it until we
have an understanding of the situation
and you still might say at the end of
this thing
i don't know what i i don't know if you
did it or not by the way for the record
i don't
i don't have an opinion on what happened
or didn't happen
now i i wasn't there i didn't see it but
again
i've had some pretty contentious
relationships and all of my living
former girlfriends
uh are accounted for so you know when i
have people telling me hey you know no
he lived with her up in 2014 in edmonton
ask him about that
ask him about the jaguar you said there
was no jaguar two minutes later there's
a jaguar but it was your job
there's a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
just very
very spoopy dude it's so stupid for me
to say there's no jaguar i drove the
jaguar down here it's a hundred thousand
dollar [ __ ] card of course i would
never say there's no jaguar
so have you been in touch with this have
you been in touch with this girl's
family at all
yeah you have absolutely absolutely her
boyfriend
her her baby's mom and the dad
so and not her parents but the guy that
actually has
kids with her the one that has victoria
i believe
and that guy spoke to me and we
basically looked at each other and he
said i know absolutely that you have
nothing to do with it
it's not i know how i know sam is and i
said dude i did everything i could to
help her out i gave her all the
opportunities that i could give her i
had my own life i had a girlfriend in
texas
i wanted to go back and get on with my
[ __ ] all she needed was a place to stay
she had that and she [ __ ] [ __ ] up
with that
and she wasn't smart with the situation
regarding vehicles and not
my jaguar not a [ __ ] chance she
didn't get it wasn't her car
she didn't have any money nobody was
giving her [ __ ] she could drive once in
a while because we're letting her drive
with us
i thought we i thought she was a crack
smoking prostitute
dude no you guys said she might have
been before she missed no you said she
was smoking crap you met her she was a
prostitute
you said that you said that dude andre
corbil said it that's what you said and
i said i had to agree with andre corbie
is probably not lying
you want to ask me when i thought that
happened years before i met her
she told me but
have you done cocaine my friend oh of
course
you're a [ __ ] loser then dude don't
talk [ __ ] to me [ __ ] yeah i had
never passed
it past the test i walked through
[ __ ] 19 funerals and never did a line
of coke in my life so now we're gonna
talk
about a [ __ ] respect thing i've never
done hard drugs she had done coke and
smoked crack before
according to me that's basically [ __ ]
samantha's in a lot of [ __ ] with god
if you believe in god so i helped her
out but i couldn't help her out if she's
gonna get [ __ ] up in florida there's
nothing i could do dude i'm not a
[ __ ] babysitter she's a grown [ __ ]
woman
she knew how to get her [ __ ] ass down
here she knew how to make phone calls
up until she wanted to get [ __ ] up and
left or stopped calling her family and
disappeared
but because i talked about her in the
past tense because the only real point
you've had to say that makes any sense
i don't think she would do that to her
family i pray to god nothing happened to
her or happens to her
but i can't [ __ ] if i'm betting money
on the situation
you know what do you think happened to
her i don't know
i had no contact with this woman i don't
keep i don't keep company i don't hold
court
with scumbags like chase and rants and
russell steven rowe
and these other people i don't i don't
surround myself in that sort of
dysfunction
who's russia russia russia stephen lowe
or whatever he's locked up in that
lovely county of brevard he's another uh
team vision dojo guy another kid diddler
not me though i never said you're a kid
diddler i'm just saying that you
the team vision dojo is the best school
that's where we send our girls right but
that's where all the
you know people that kill their [ __ ]
allegedly kill their pregnant stepmother
like that and selmo guy
and chase and rance and his brother and
[ __ ] russell steven rowe it's just
teddy you could you could at least level
me and say that look you
are a a an unusual fella
you uh you don't live a very
conventional life
uh and you you have been known at times
to be a little eccentric am i am i
off base by saying that not at all not
at all
and and were you not doing videos with
jason really
you say like i barely knew jason but
were you guys not doing custom matches
with except for one time ever
maybe way back in with luke but i never
did customs of chasing by myself
under the name teddy trouble no i meant
it on teddy troubleshit but i don't
think maybe jason ends up putting the
tape through his guys to get it released
i don't know but i wasn't doing
personally with chase and jason's one of
the guys
i've known him for a long time but on
and off because i've only come down to
florida for maybe
three or four days at a time five times
ten maybe
maybe five times in ten years i came
down but if i ever saw him he'd be the
guy that might pick me up at the airport
because he came up to canada and he
trained with us
and he seemed like a nice guy then and i
would imagine he helped out a ton of
guys after whatever happened with that
girl i always say the same thing
[ __ ] that shit's [ __ ] crazy man
that's not the smartest move and it
[ __ ] is going to cost you probably
for years but you know what
i'm not going to hold anything against
you because [ __ ] it's not my spot i
[ __ ] feel probably like if it
happened to me
[ __ ] i'd have to go through hell and
it could happen to you maybe it's a
stupid thing but down the road i would
hope that you're somehow
vindicated or forgiven if you actually
be a good person after that and jason
seemed to always be a good person he
[ __ ] up
but then after that i saw him help out a
lot of people you know that's all i can
say he might be a piece of [ __ ] to you
but i saw him help out a lot of guys man
that's all i could say you know i mean
i'm not getting involved in what
happened because
everybody [ __ ] up you know i [ __ ] i
feel terrible for a lot of other things
that happen in wrestling but
sometimes guys got away with it and
sometimes guys get caught and shoot
interviews later where guys
talk about [ __ ] that happened it's like
man that's [ __ ] up you know and i hear
way more [ __ ] up [ __ ] that happened
with
this other wrestler than it happened
personally with the chasing situation so
again all i can do is go there's a place
to train
she wanted to do mma the florida pla
florida mma scene is the best
from what i was told and there's some
people that are down here that do all
the amateur wrestling
i know all the families they do
everything she was lined up to to do mma
and have some good fights and she knew
she has
she knew she was going to get punched
it's for real and once she understood
that guess what it was she didn't want
to do it
so she got a job landscaping and was
proud of
she was happy she remember she said she
was glad and that was the only time i
even talked to her was one practice and
then after that she said she's just
gonna make money landscaping she gets
180 bucks a day
and she got a job through somebody that
was doing uh photography work in uh
in chasing school and a bunch of the
other shows so that was last time i
talked to her
but there's this recurring theme like in
your videos and when i when i talk to
you right now
there's this weird like recurring theme
where it's like how it affects the
person who did the thing like with you
it's like oh samantha disappeared and
now i'm paying for it i'm losing gigs
when it's chasing rants it's like oh so
he pressured a 15 year old to [ __ ] him
without a
shower and he got caught on tape with
the cops trying to get her to [ __ ]
recant her story
but it affected him like oh man he made
a dumb move and now it's going to cost
him the rest of his career
like it seems to be there seems to be
little to no
there seems to be little to no
consideration
for the victims or alleged victims in
these cases
samantha fiddler what about her kids
what about the young woman
who chase and rants who's been convicted
of [ __ ] multiple times at his home
what about like
instead of worrying about how it affects
chase and rants in his [ __ ] school
what about a moment to because you keep
playing it down like it's this little
thing
hey maybe [ __ ] up no i got a dui once
that's [ __ ] up
you know what i mean i've been in a fist
fight here now and again in my life
that's [ __ ] up
but i've never i've never in my life
brought a 15 year old girl into my
[ __ ] home
and pressured them into having sex with
me and then
was recorded on the phone with the cops
trying to pressure her into
recanting her story about [ __ ] me but
you're not recanting did you ever smoke
crack by the way or did you ever
you didn't get that far yeah no i
freebased a little coke in my day but
again i didn't [ __ ] kids and none of my
girls are missing
not crack i got freebase coke there's a
difference crack has too many additives
teddy teddy i don't believe for one
second you've gotten
all this way in life and only smoked
weed you can lie to us all you want but
you're lying
you have a habit of of stretching the
truth
i am an honest man the only difference
between you and me is i'm an open book
that's [ __ ] stupid you have a
different story every time i gotta be
disappointed to hear you say that you
freebased a little coke what was so bad
with life that you decided to [ __ ]
flush your brain down the toilet for 30
seconds
that's that's what it is my life was bad
see listen teddy the only difference
between me
opening up about my life but you're not
no i am a real man because i actually
tell people about my [ __ ] life and my
mistakes you make
no mistakes in your own mind every time
you're [ __ ] cutting a promo it's just
oh this is oh what was me everybody's
mean to teddy hart
oh i didn't do anything and everybody's
just meaning me even though i know show
events
and i know triple a shows and mlw fired
me for no reason
because i'm an innocent teddy hard and i
never did anything wrong to anyone
i've seen you pick cats up by their
[ __ ] tail yeah they're degenerative
mlw is nice enough to give it to me it's
an angle dude we're trying to work
[ __ ] people to make money
oh so they didn't find you this is just
fine because you're trying to humiliate
a guy like me i'm trying to be your
friend
no you're humiliating you [ __ ] people
asking
do you recommend telling your student if
you had a mentor you're a jedi master
and you had an apprentice and the guy
behind it you know you wanted to impress
him would you tell him to smoke crack
and do coke and [ __ ] be a drunk
no but i certainly wouldn't lie about my
own [ __ ] experiences
unlike present company because i'm sorry
dude nobody [ __ ] believes that you
made it this far
and act this weird and and babble this
much
nervously and you're not and you're not
maybe a little bit
come on come on man come on
maybe a lot maybe more people like you
than you never busted your knee and took
a pain pill come on dude
you're not perfect you try to present
yourself in a way where you're watching
you watch my [ __ ] miss record on
wrestling moves for you who claps for me
because there's no extra bonus for
hitting the moonsault off the top or the
full twist or the [ __ ] split leg to
the floor
or brian cage giving you the f5 off the
top ropes for [ __ ] 800 people in a
bar show
but 8 million people are watching it
over the next 10 years so i think i'm
wrestling in front of the whole [ __ ]
world
so guys like you can go that is kind of
funny that little [ __ ] prick's been
dropped off his head on cages and off
the cement and he's still walking at 40
years old
and they said the dynamite kid did a lot
of crazy [ __ ] i'm just asking you to
watch my highlight reel
and put it up against any [ __ ]
on the planet and go and i never got
paid to do any of this [ __ ]
i get your point teddy but nobody here
ever said that you're a shitty wrestler
we just there are many people that are
under the impression that you're a
shitty guy
you're a shitty person you're not
perfect teddy you're a megalomaniac
i've met types like you i've met a
million people like you in my life
you're a dime a dozen and gives guys
[ __ ]
help and pays money for other guys boots
and helps guys
i know you're good at putting yourself
over teddy a lot of people
a lot of people help people and they
don't [ __ ] bring it up every time
they're called into question
teddy dude i told the truth but i never
[ __ ] lied about [ __ ] and i don't have
to lie now i cut myself in [ __ ] half
on tv
by talking [ __ ] 20 years ago i'm not
stupid but i don't know whenever i never
had a bad match or hurt one [ __ ]
in my life if i wanted to be a wrestler
i would have shut my mouth and done
[ __ ] probably the right thing
which is trained a little harder in the
gym instead of doing gymnastics and
learning how to [ __ ] do moves by
watching figure skaters
and dancing i've invented more moves
than anybody in the wrestling world dude
not to be a [ __ ] hater
but the only reason i'm talking to you
is because someday you're gonna have to
come out and hang out with me and go to
a [ __ ] bar and have a drink and look
me eye to eye and you're gonna say man i
couldn't [ __ ] believe
i talked that much [ __ ] to you and i'm
gonna say no [ __ ] dude but i like when
you challenge me
because you have to create a friend for
life i'd like you'd have to watch a
highlight video after this just one i'll
send you one you tell me after that if
you think a guy like me is going to hurt
anybody and god will let me [ __ ] live
or walk after how many dumb moves have i
done off the top ropes dude to the floor
it's in god's hands i always say that in
your hands as a fan
you keep me safe see that's another i'd
rather have your blessing when you're
watching me wrestle that you don't want
to see me get [ __ ] hurt
i don't want to see anybody get hurt
teddy i don't want to see anybody get
hurt i don't have it in for you
what i have it in for is that you are
you are you are a bit of a megalomaniac
you do have a tendency to babble a lot
contradict yourself
put yourself over a lot you like to tell
people about all the good things you've
done
you say a lot of weird things that like
like god is with me and god is has
ordained me and all this weird [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] crazy people talk
that's crazy people talk you might have
blessed me with a [ __ ] lucky
streak of moves and 25 years of safety
because people like you have a special
power i believe that you keep me safe
and all the wrestlers that actually work
hard
you fans have a special power when you
watch you keep us safe because no
i've never seen another sport where guys
should break their necks and be [ __ ]
dead more than
indie wrestling and somehow indie
wrestling has kept these guys alive now
and all the best wrestlers on tv are all
from indie wrestlers
there's no superstars ever just created
everyone that came up basically came as
an indie wrestler
and that's because people like you if
you're a real wrestling fan you somehow
gave us a force field not to get hurt
so that's why i even give you five
minutes of my time you know just because
i'd rather have your [ __ ] love and
respect down the road as a fan
because it's one more guy protecting me
from a wheelchair
people simply want the truth
that's what can i give all right so
between november
and december 2016. well where were we
yeah what shows were you doing
where we at because that's a big gap bud
that's a whole month this girl went
missing before you were in a jail cell
like can you honestly look back to four
years ago at one month and be like this
is exactly what i was doing yes
yes yes maria maria it's it's called
doing it's called doing my research it's
called doing my facts
i i actually unlike you guys i showed up
on time i prepared last night i got my
no like
it's it's called you know you know no
showing events in mexico
just to answer the question where were
you when i told him podcast he was
laughing he didn't want to [ __ ] talk
to you
come on i'm trying to have no interest
in doing this but i was like hey i think
it's good publicity like we'll get our
name out there a little bit maybe
we should do it i still think this guy
has to end up being my friend somehow
he's still trying to be feisty no i
think it's funny that you prepared notes
if you thought that we gave a [ __ ] about
it
you know i care about it i care about
she doesn't understand because
i think i think you're a guy that's
gonna end up being a teddy heart
spokesman
you're gonna say man i [ __ ] this guy
over by talking that much [ __ ] to him
and realize that i don't contradict
myself but i never said i was ordained
and if you're that if you're as smart as
i think you are then you and i have to
have a real conversation
at a bar and let me buy you a meal and
hang out with me for a couple hours
and make sure you get home safe and then
call daddy or mommy or whoever you got
to call or your friends and say
i made it home with teddy already ended
up giving me a hug the guy was real
weird he gave me a jacket and
he said you're the only guy to challenge
me on the truth if i'm a piece of [ __ ]
that would hurt a woman definitely
challenge me but
not my thing dude that's awesome i'm not
saying you heard anybody but i am saying
that you can't account for times
there's time gaps you're literally
there's literally
published articles in rolling stone
disputing what you're telling me which
is that you never dated
disputing your own words in your own
[ __ ] video a couple weeks ago you
said i only dated her for a little bit
but dude
whatever so it's it's literally it's a
different story every time
dating is someone you're kind of on and
off seeing you know it's not serious
girlfriend boyfriend is like this
okay well he said he never [ __ ] her so
that's kind of just because i wasn't
having sex with her doesn't mean she
wasn't i guess with me but i wasn't
having sex with her
so that's all i can tell you that that
was the situation i wasn't [ __ ]
having
i wasn't [ __ ] dealing with that
situation she was already doing
it wasn't worth she needs a fourth kid
i'm not gonna
i already have the girlfriend headache
in [ __ ] uh dallas trust me man i
wasn't trying to get another headache
do you understand that when when when
when you see
many many many uh written accounts in in
actual legitimate media
calling her your girlfriend and now it's
now she never it's like she
by this time next year she won't even
have existed it'll be like oh i never
met her in my life i don't even know who
that is
never said that though you're trying to
spend words again i don't know why you
keep trying to spin [ __ ] if you really
think i did it
i haven't spun [ __ ] teddy you gotta slow
down with the [ __ ] weed bro
you gotta slow down with the [ __ ]
weed you don't even remember what you
put out on the [ __ ] internet
i've given you enough time on it no i'm
not giving you
any more answers i talk to the cops i
talk to judges i have a lawyer involved
you can say what you want to say dude i
already said what i needed to say so
it's if you want to talk about something
else i'm cool to talk about it but if
you keep bringing up the samantha
fiddler thing for me it's been addressed
i gave way more time than i wanted to on
it and it's been addressed
what the [ __ ] do you think we're gonna
talk about tonight how to properly tuck
your chin when you're taking a powerbomb
like
of course i was gonna talk about this
you coming right out the g i was gonna
give you guys
i was gonna front load the promotion
part hey show the belt and talk about
your channel a little bit
and then you [ __ ] and then you just
came out the gate screaming about murder
so of course i'm gonna go into the
murder thing
hey teddy somebody wants to know are you
a freemason are you a freemason
is that another question do you want to
talk to the guys that i work with
is that a free so you're oh boy all
right so that's all right so your free
match that's fine
can i give you the number i'm going to
give you his phone number because you um
and he's just going to tell you
don't give numbers out on the air do not
dox phone numbers on the air
because you want to challenge it then
better call me back after this phone
call is over on a private phone line and
then give me a call and obviously text
me
who you are your number and then you can
call my friend
and just ask him what i represent okay
hmm
all right well look guys we're at the
top of the hour here do you say you want
to promote anything
yeah you when are you gonna come out and
do a vlog with me
and maria why what city do you live in
oh we'll get into that off the air it's
fine i'm i'm easy to find but just so do
you guys want to promote anything i'll
be in touch don't worry i'm not a
stranger
i haven't shied away from anything for
life man because you're gonna have to be
proven wrong
and then after that you're gonna owe me
an apology and a hug and then after that
you can come to six flags with me or
disney i hope you ride roller coasters
and [ __ ] have a friend for life
because at least you gave me an hour of
your time and you seemed like a smart
dude i challenged the [ __ ] out of it if
i could if i actually thought it and
it's worth it for you to talk about just
that
then you must have a few other things
you want to talk about off the air i
hope do you smoke marijuana now
of course yeah i don't i don't do any
cocaine or any drugs anymore god so at
least we're
asking so at least we're back yeah can
we can we ask you we never got to ask
him anything he just surprised me the
whole time with this [ __ ]
do you guys want to promote anything
twitter you want to promote do you want
to promote the channel do you guys want
to give a
get any shows coming up you know promote
it out we got like over
2 000 people watching right now um
spring of honor this weekend tomorrow
yeah
she's got during the honor show where
are we tomorrow atlanta
we're in atlanta tomorrow was it center
stage is it for you
is it called is it saturday saturday
saturday and then sunday where every
sunday
where is it five hours from it's my
schedule i have a bad memory for dates
that's why i have these
actually opened up these silly iphones
so
it's very slow on the phone all right
well at teddy hart is back
on twitter if you guys want to follow
them there maria and ted's unfiltered
adventures here on youtube you guys
don't need any introduction
of course you can track them on there
and uh ring of honor this weekend in uh
atlanta if you guys are gonna is that a
pay-per-view
is that uh is that like a pay-per-view
type deal or
no just a tv taping all right tv taping
uh in atlanta
uh thank you guys uh appreciate you guys
coming on thanks for joining me tonight
we'll do it again we'll
be calmer next time we need a part two
for sure that was not can i
uh can i ask you you're are you out of
time or do you have time
well yeah we're at the it's 11 51 the
show ends at 12. so i got to do my uh
my little ending you know donations and
stuff like that
okay cool and i this when you have some
time
give me a call after if you don't mind
yeah that's fine you name me up that's
fine
whatever it's fine and you're not you're
not pulling any tape recorder [ __ ]
because i would imagine that that's just
so i
ask you ahead of time like i wouldn't be
trying if you wanted hypocrite
conversations we can both just say at
the beginning of the conversation
no if i'm if i'm not on the air i
[ __ ] no it's fine
if i'm not on the air i'm not rolling
tape i'm not some kind of cop and i
certainly look despite what you think i
don't have it in for you man it's just
that there was a lot of
inconsistencies and people wanted them
addressed and i have
a uh i have a duty to my fans just like
you do to your fans
i understand that's why that's why i'm
asking you after you you can
we can talk more and then you can figure
it out and then if it's worth it to you
to be
that that guy that really wants to find
out the truth it's really easy for you
just to come down here
and then you can understand after that
it's impossible for
what what can't you tell me what is what
has to be private like that's what's
weird to me it's
the truth the truth should be [ __ ] i
don't want it i don't want to marry some
i don't want to bury somebody that's
possibly dead or missing well you
already called her a crack smoking
prostitute who barely saw our kids so i
mean i don't know what else is going to
be
like that's why i said i didn't want to
have to go that far but i didn't say
that andre corbin said that
and you're asking if andre corbie is
lying and i said i would have to
probably agree that she may have done
that type of stuff to make money to feed
her three kids
which is probably pretty terrible but i
don't you know
and and prostitution's legal in alberta
so it wasn't she was breaking the law
she if she was doing it she probably had
a license or she was working at a strip
club
and she was making money doing other
[ __ ] in the strip club that's probably
what that would be
that's that's what that means so all
right
different than in the states i mean just
different rules so
well look man i'll be in touch let me uh
let me wrap things up and uh yeah we'll
we'll talk soon i promise you seem like
a pretty cool guy man so i'm happy you
gave me that
talk and maybe again i'm not hoping
anything crazy but if we could be
friends someday that would be pretty
cool because i would hope at the end of
the day
uh once you're done this fact searching
[ __ ] about her which is admirable
when you get on to being friends with me
or we never talk again because
you know i mean one of the two has to
eventually happen so
all right fair enough thank you guys so
much uh teddy hart marie manic uh that
was uh
that was something huh i was uh
that was actually uh it got hot got a
little hot didn't it
and again look i wanted to be not you
guys know i mean i've been
telegraphing this for days now i've been
saying i wanna
you know i wanted to be uh respectful
wanted to come out the gate a little
slow you know a little foreplay
he kind of came at me a little hard i
kind of went back a little bit harder
uh it was a lot of a lot of people came
in very hot
people coming in hot so uh that was uh
that was something else man i was a that
was definitely a
a night wave for the [ __ ] books